Hello,
and welcome.
Thank you, Derek.
I will pop that on the screen. Thank
you. Today, I am joined by Derek Ressons,
the author and maintainer and all around nice
person
surrounding xdebug.
How are you, Derek?
I'm good. Yourself? It's been a beautiful day
today.
It has, which has made my video set
up a little bit more difficult than I
wanted it to be. But Yeah. I've been
I've
been hacking on SSL related the whole day,
so there we go.
Oh, nice. Any nice long walks today? You've
been walking the chip station. Right?
Oh, yeah. Not today. That's usually a weekend
thing, so that's back for Saturday and Sunday.
Yeah.
Plan is to walk the length of all
the London tube lines.
Yeah. No easy things there.
Yeah. It's just not it's not hard. It
just takes a long time.
Yeah. Yeah.
So today,
you've
very graciously offered to join me
and teach me how to profile PHP applications
with xdebug.
Right.
Alright. Excellent.
So before we get started on that, what
I would like to do is say that
we do have a Discord where people can
come and chat and leave questions. You are
also very welcome to leave questions on YouTube.
However, if you are feeling brave and you
wish to pop into the stream and join
us live to ask your question and have
a short discussion, then we will try and
fit that in towards the end. If you
wanna do that, drop me a message on
Discord, and we will try to sort it
out.
Now to get started today,
we
need my screen to be shared.
And we will do this.
And by the power of magic, we are
in.
So I'm starting off with a pretty
sorry. Did you say something there, Derek?
No. I just need to make sure that
I increase the font size on this because
I can't read that. There we go. That's
a bit better. Yeah. So the font size
on the sidebar, I do not know how
to make that bigger without zooming in on
the whole thing because I think it's, like,
an electron app. I can't remember what code
is. But the text editor should be nice
and large for us. Yes. That I can
write.
Excellent.
And, hopefully, your terminal's as well.
Yeah. My terminal
Oh, that's easy peasy.
You know, I've I just now leave it
like this all the time. So even when
I'm coding on my own and it's not
for a stream, I just present it with
this massive text. And you know what? It's
it's oddly satisfying. Like, I don't need to
see 14 functions at once. I just need
to see see what Yeah. It's true. And
that is, like, funny how that goes. Let
me actually put my face in your whole
screen because you've cut me off a little
bit. There we go. Oh, hi, Ruth. Sorry
about that.
Been live moving your face to the center
of the screen. Pretty
Now you can't see my lovely backgrounds.
We can see better, but don't worry. I
can I can see it? Okay.
So I'm starting from a clean slate today.
Anyone who's watched the stream before will know
that I have a lot of PHP experience,
but I haven't really got any modern PHP
experience. I haven't really written a lot of
PHP in the last four to five years,
which means that my computer setup right now
comes with whatever the Mac gives me.
I have PHP 7.3,
and I installed Composer through brew. But I
haven't done anything else. Nothing else is done
in advance of this session.
Do you have any home brew setups or
not?
I do have homebrew available. We can install
anything that we need to get going. Yeah.
So get rid get first thing I would
always recommend, get rid of the PHP that
comes with the Mac because I don't know
what they've done to it, but it doesn't
behave as it should.
It doesn't behave as it should. Okay. Even
tells it even it even tells you when
you type PHP. Right?
So yeah. Because I'm also running Big Sur,
living life on the edge, it now says
PHP is not recommended. But I think what
they actually mean is is no longer gonna
ship by default with the next version. So
it's a really terrible message or some developer
having a very bad joke.
So can I just do brew install PHP?
Yes.
I think so. I don't use a Mac.
I'm just guessing it.
I don't really use a Mac either. It's
something that I took on as part of
my new role with Packet, and I'm still
very much getting used to it. I mess
my tiling window manager.
That's for sure. Yeah.
Okay. So let's go over the plan of
that homebrew that's just breathing. Okay. So I've
okay. So I lied. I have said a
couple of things up. So when we were
talking I got a fear yesterday, Derek, I
should say, when you tweeted me saying, I
hope you've got a slow PHP application. And
I was like, shit. I never thought about
what we'd actually profile.
So I got my thinking hat on. And
I figured we could start with a really
trivial trivial example where we would Right. Run
the pro profiler on a one line Huddl
world application.
Mhmm. I don't think we're gonna lot out
of it, but I think just to see
the tooling and the setup and a simple
call graph may be beneficial. At least for
me, I wanna see it in the simplest
form before we break it with the the
harder stuff.
And then I thought about how can we
make it a little bit more interesting? And
I thought, well, recursion is generally interesting when
it comes to profiling.
So I created a very small factorial function
that is recursive,
and we can throw some different values into
this.
And I thought, depending on how we get
on with that
really, I should have run this plan be
for you beforehand, but we'll just do that.
I thought we could inject
some arbitrary
errors
where we add a sleep.
Now we're looking at this now, but I
thought if we can I I want to
see if we can use the profile to
identify what is causing certain bottlenecks rather than
just is the factorial function randomly
coming out of that time? I don't know.
It just Yeah. We'll see.
Do you have the
profiling front end installed?
You didn't think about it either, did you?
Versus Code, I'm assuming it has some sort
of front end. Nah. It's got a deep
Oh, yeah? No. It doesn't do profiling front
ends. Luckily, I have a homebrew formula for
you there too. Okay.
Alright. That's how just googled.
Okay.
The next
I I set aside four examples. The next
one being, I figured we could do a
composer with a really small composer JSON. You
can see I just got two packages here,
and we can actually profile composer itself
before tackling something much larger. Now that's just
a project I found on GitHub called Zulu.
It seems to be like a CMS system
built on Laravel or Symphony. I can't remember.
It's Symphony.
And it has a lot of dependencies.
At least, it's quite hefty. And I did
run a composer install before this and then
blew away the vendor folder and the log
file. It took around a minute, I believe.
So, hopefully, that gets us something substantial that
we can take a look at the call
graph and the profiles, etcetera. Yeah. It's usually
the the the having the caches available is
not usually the problem because that's you're just
waiting for network IO, and who cares about
that?
Exactly. I'm more interested than the dependency graph
resolution and how long that takes. Yeah. So
for that, it's actually better to have the
cache in place, but we'll get there when
we get there.
Excellent. So
what do I need to do first?
Alright.
Let's have a look back at your terminal,
whether you actually have
PHP going now.
We have seven five four dot 10 just
coming down the pipe now. So
Alright.
If you wouldn't mind starting another terminal where
you can add some more things
Indeed. Then we then it can run that
while we
when we do actual things.
Okay. So there's a home also brew install,
and then it's called q cache grind.
Q? The
letter q and a cache grant.
Cache grant. Grains? Yep. No. Without yes.
Cache grant? Yep.
Is that all? Yep. Well,
whether works is to be seen, but
So what is this that I'm installing? Is
it front end for for xdebug specifically or
profiles in general? It's actually
not specific for xdebug. The profiling format that
xdebug outputs is actually
something that comes out of Vellgrind's tooling. Vellgrind
is like a low level memory profiling CPU
emulating tool
that also allows you to make profiles
of
c programs or c plus plus programs. And
because I don't know how to write front
ends, especially not nice looking functional graphical front
ends, I just saw the formats for xdebug
so that it uses the same. We don't
really have to look at this. For
now, we first need to get the profiler
going. So just let it sit in the
background for a while, and let's see what
we're going on. Alright. So Okay. That's still
that's still the wrong one. Right? Because
where did it install PHP?
Where did where did Brew install it?
May want me to do a BrewLink.
Okay. Oh, in fact, it probably just wants
me to pop open a new terminal, doesn't
it? So
Yeah. So this is the intricacies that I
don't really know.
Magic.
Right? There we
Okay. So
is is peccl available with this
or not? P e c l. Can you
just type in and see what it is?
Otherwise, you might yeah. Excellent. So peccl
install xdebug.
And this is me installing the PHP
extension xdebug. Right? Yes. Yeah. There used to
be homebrew formulas for all the extensions, but
I stopped doing that.
So you now have to use peckle to
install these things.
You got a few errors, but you just
ignore them.
That's great advice in general, I feel.
It's just this is this is the the
so maxed out themselves as being Unix, but
it is kind of weird.
But, yeah, now we have to wait for
it to it's So I have I
have anticipated us running into some sort of
Mac issues,
and I did spin up a Linux machine
on Packet Cloud just in case we need
it. So So there's somebody asking at chats,
would that grind Docker container would also work
as good as key cache grind?
I don't think so. I think that grind
is good for oh, fancy.
You got the questions on here. Yep.
So the web client is also a useful
tool,
but it is not nearly as powerful as
q q cache client or the two the
variant that I use is called k cache
client, which is
the same tool but with a slightly different
looking from that. The k stands for k
d e and the q stands for QT.
Of course, as you know, KD is just
a shell around QT or QT or whatever
people want to pronounce that.
But, no, I I don't think a web
client container or web grinds in general is
as nice or as useful as
q cache grinds or cache cache grinds.
However, it's a lot easier to pronounce.
I'll give it that.
Alright. Did it did it install?
Yes. We have both available now. We have
two cache grind, and I have xdebug enabled
in my PHP.
Can you minus v? Yeah. Just do minus
v.
And it's e? V for v. Yeah.
It shows up. Excellent. Now the only thing
that you might have to be careful of
is that xdebug is loaded after opcache.
And in your case, it's loaded before op
cache.
Now this
shouldn't cause any problems with profiling,
but I would
advise not to have them this way around.
Okay. So do should we change that in
the PHP NA? Yeah. So if you type
PHP minus minus I and I,
two minuses.
It'll tell you which files it loads,
and you see that
what's has done is installed it into PHP
I nine,
but it really should have put it in
a separate file like x op cache has
done. I don't I don't know what the
two doesn't do that. So what we need
to do is Put it there. What we
need to do is remove it from PHP
I nine.
At the top. It's at the top.
First line.
Delete delete this line,
and I'll leave just save the file.
And now create this new file that is
called x dash
xdebug.
Not any. Yep. And then
the thing that you just removed, paste it
back in there.
Okay. Z zent underscore exten extension
equals xdebug.
I would not recommend spaces or quotes.
Think so?
Get rid of the quotes. Don't don't need
them.
I love
the reason why I say don't use quotes
is because people copy and paste this from
websites,
and invariably, the quotes have been replaced by
the curly quotes, and then it doesn't work.
So I would always say,
I I I do the minimalist approach. If
you don't need it, don't enter it anyway.
PHP minus v should now have it the
right way around.
Ta da.
And I'll verify whether that's what it does
here. There we go. So, ideally, the tool
knows about these things and does these things
right, but
it doesn't.
That's why I think the homebrew formulas also
have been kept because they'd handle these things
correctly.
Anyhow, it is loaded.
Excellent.
Now we just need to enable the profiler.
And how do we do that?
Open up the any file that you've just
created
Yep.
And add the new line
saying profiler.
Sorry. Xdebug dot
underscore enable equals one.
And if you now type a PHP minus
minus
r I xdebug
no. With a space after the I. Sorry.
And as
if you scroll up a little bit, you
can
so the line that I was interested in,
scroll three three or four more. There we
go. So it tells you the profile is
on,
what the output directory is,
Is that a valid directory?
Yes. Type it.
It's empty. Even better. Okay.
So now if you request your PHP script,
it should create a profile file. So if
you type PHP,
space, the name of your scripts.
I'm not in the record. So I go
into my hello world directory.
Yeah. And I can just do PHP main
dot PHP. Yes.
By magic, I have a profile. Yes.
You have a profile file. Exactly.
Now what I if you do this for
websites, I would actually recommend you turn on
the trigger and stat and install a browser
extension,
but we might have a look at that
later
Yeah. Sure. If we have time. Any case,
we have this cache client dot out file.
Do you want to open it? Let's see
what's in there.
Barack
dev cache client.
K.
Well, what do you see here? I see
the command that was run on the scripts.
I see
oh, so it's got some events,
which I guess are the function calls with
some numeric values.
Okay. So the the numeric values are basically
an index number so that the next time
it sees the same file,
it wouldn't
include the file name and just include the
number.
It's just a clever way of
basically, like an index creation,
but it's
doesn't matter.
It's just a way of the format works.
And then we have the one one eighty
eight and thirty two. That's basically stands for
line one.
It took a hundred and eighty eight
microseconds.
I'd hope it's not milliseconds for Hello World.
Yeah. Microseconds. Microseconds,
and then it took 32 bytes of memory.
And then you get the summary that it
the actually, whole full execution took
one dot four milliseconds, and it took 431
parts parts of memory. However, this is not
how you'd look at these files. Right? And
you just want to make sure that the
first time you do that, we have a
look at this to see what is actually
in here. But
the way how I would view this is
by using q cache client, or in my
case, k cache client. So you can q
cache client,
and then specify the file name behind.
Alright.
Stuff.
There we go. Yeah.
Okay.
Can you
make this bigger?
I also don't know how to
zoom in there.
Is this not something that your your operator
system provides?
So I could
do this.
That makes it weird. That changed absolutely nothing.
Anyway,
yeah. We'll try to make it work.
Can you at least make it full screen
now so we don't get distracted by QCache
currents error messages?
Oh, dear god. This is small. How do
I make this bigger for myself so I
actually can see it?
So maybe just an electron,
file grain, cash grain thing that we could
use, which would allow me to zoom or
maybe a web one that can open.
Anyway, I've yeah. I if it's full screen,
it works for me.
I can just about see this. But, yeah,
there's not a lot of information in here.
And
on the so on the on the left
hand side, you have all the function calls.
When this case is only main
because
yeah. There's sorry.
Because you didn't call any functions.
On the right hand side, you have
a few tabs. If you click on source
code tab,
this is fifth one,
you can actually see your source code. So
that's handy.
But echo is not a function call, so
you can't really see anything in here.
So it doesn't really do it show you
it can't show you more because there's nothing
to show.
And so our
the echo on a function call? Just Yeah.
Sure.
Absolutely.
Okay.
So what we're saying is that's not very
interesting, but if we do function
my echo
string
oh, I can do this there. Right?
And then we could do echo
string. We could do that since PHP seven
zero already,
which has been out for five years.
Okay. So if I Yep. Run this again,
we'll get a new profile.
Yep.
And we can open this.
Yeah. It's open. So there there's actually a
trick
that it doesn't
change the file name
because at the moment, it uses the process
ID
Okay. Which is what's cache client's standard way
of doing things are, but you don't have
to do it.
And there's ways of changing the output format
so that if you run it from the
same directory, it will always be the same
file
if you want to do that.
Yeah. It may make it a bit easier
for today.
So you'd be typing down this a lot.
Okay. Open the any file again then.
Okay.
User
You
does control r does control r
So I did, but the problem is I
have pair director history. So I need to
go up and then do them.
Oh, okay. So that is usually a feature,
but not at the moment. Yes. So
the setting is xdebug dot
profiler
Profiler underscore
underscore outputs
underscore name
Yep.
Equals
and now you cache dot out
dot
I wasn't quite done yet.
Don't go ahead of yourself. Dot percent c.
So the thing the thing behind the percent
sign is a form of specify, and the
documentation lists a whole bunch of them.
The c stands for the
CRC 32 of your current direct working directory,
Whereas by default, b two p, which is
your process ID, but there's a whole bunch
more,
such as the full
the like, the the h t p URL,
for example, if you want. So that means
that if I so I could have done
that without the percentage to you. Right? But
it means if I changed directory and profiled
something else, then
I would overwrite that last profile. So this
incorporates the file name or directory path into
that. Is that right? Just the directory part
at the moment. Yeah. Alright. Okay.
But, yeah, you can also do the parts
and other things. There's there's a whole bunch
of settings if you want to look at
the documentation.
Yep.
Okay. So if I run that again
Now you should have, of course, the third
one
Yep.
Which is to but that one will never
change.
Oh, once you run it from this directory.
And now you as you can see, you
have two functions. Right?
Yes.
We do. Okay. So our source code is
gonna be updated,
and we have two calls over here. So
we've got main followed by the my echo.
Okay. Cool. Right. So there's a few interesting
columns here, which will be more interesting once
we have some more function calls. But on
the left hand side, you have includes include,
it says.
All the way to the left. All the
way to the Yep. Yep. Yep. Okay. Yep.
Include. In Incl stands for inclusive, not include.
Inclusive. Okay. And self stands for self. So,
basically, what these things mean that inclusive
means all the time spent in this function
and all the functions it has called,
whereas self says only
the time spent in this function. So theoretically,
in simple examples, if you add all the
self times
if you add them altogether,
it should end up at a %,
which
Which it is. At the moment, it does.
There is, of course, often rounding errors in
there, and there's recursion in there that makes
that not work. But in a simple example,
that should all add up to a hundred
because,
well, you can't spend time twice. Right?
Okay. Makes sense. Okay. And
then on your right hand side,
there is for example, click on map.
K. Yeah. And now
something doesn't render for me correctly
because the whole screen should be blue.
So the left hand side, which looks white
on the preview, is green for me with
a little bit on the blue. So it's
like the that seems to represent the self
values mapped out with colors.
Yep. Pretty much true. So this is a
way of seeing in one overview is
the things that have a large area stacked
on top of stuff
is where a lot of time is being
taken. So in this case, what you would
expect, 80% is spent in just main
where that is mostly overhead of parsing it,
to be fair. And then on the and
then the 20%
should be the the blue bit that is
then the my echo.
Yep. Perfect. And if we have more interesting
things, we can see more interesting information. But
there you go. Now on the bottom half,
if you click on call graph
all
the way all the way in the bottom.
There we go. Let's hope that works better.
Just check if click on call graph.
It's working for me, but it's not updating
on.
Oh, I just have to change change screen
and then magically
Hey. Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. What can I say?
Yeah.
I've never seen that issue before, but, hey,
now we know it, we can work around
it. Yes. But, yeah, you can see the
call graph. Basically, you see in the graph
which functions calls which function, how often and
how much time we'll spend in these functions.
And that,
once we have something more interesting to show,
will tell us what is taking up the
most amount of time or what is the
the slow path to be to be precise.
So shall we find a example that is
more interesting than hello, world?
Sounds like a good idea.
I agree.
So if we
take a look at our factorial You
need to do the screen search thing again.
That is
peculiar. Okay.
How about my factorial functions? That should be
look. You mentioned the recursion this week. He
went through the hello world from there and
said that the values may not add up.
So I guess I was fortunate enough that
I had some recursion.
Would you please alter braces around the return?
No. The top one. The ones in line
five and seven.
Was that new either? Is that personal
It's also not changing, by the way.
Well, that is let's just turn off my
screen share and then reshare.
That is weird.
You can't admire the Tower Bridge at night
for a moment here.
Alright. So if I
yeah. Okay. I think we're okay. So
not a personal well, yes, personal preference,
but
in the xdebug version that you still run
two nine
with all the PHP version that sometimes gets
line numbers on the wrong places.
And Okay. Hence, step debugging and profiling
looks strange,
although it is
something that PHP internally does. So I would
always suggest to other braces. It's also what
in is there in most coding standards.
Alright. Good to hear that. Good. Yep.
Alright. Let's run it.
Pick a number.
721.
So because my PHP is a little rusty,
I wasn't sure if it read an input,
so I have just decided to pull it
from the environment,
which is why we're using this sometime.
Okay.
That's brilliant.
Is it? It looks like an error.
K. Scroll up. Let's see what you've done.
Oh, it's because I've not casted it to
an end.
Although it worked when I made Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Tested this code.
That's not how you cast it in.
You you do in in between parentheses in
front of what you're casting.
It's not go.
Are you sure it's not go? That's that's
what I write mostly these days. Okay. So
to catch I know. I can tell.
Yeah. Put in put in in parenthesis.
And and oh, like c. Like okay. Got
it.
Yes. Like c. There we go. That's how
you do that.
The first if if that's
one is true, factorial of a negative number
as one?
If less than or equal to one,
return one.
That's okay. Okay.
I think so.
Let's run this. Index number.
I can test this through the Let's do
the proper
way. Okay. Open up your PHP file.
You're just doing this how how does she
how you should do this.
The number is the int cost of arc
v one.
Yeah.
And then arc v yeah. Exactly. Don't forget
your semicolon. It's not go.
So now you just have to pass that
here. Right? Yes.
That
was a
Okay.
Well, you have a bug in your code,
mate,
because
this is xdebug telling you if you see
the whole error message,
pipe what you type to to less and
you'll see what I mean.
There's 250 lines you don't want to scroll
up.
So I only tested the small numbers, and
it works.
So it's the big number that's causing the
error. Okay. So let's run over seven two
one and put
errors to log. Correct? Yeah. But that will
it's standard output.
So we'll move it to you.
Maximum function nesting level of 256.
Yeah.
You know what that means?
Well, I was assuming that this was tail
call optimized, and that would be okay. But
I'm assuming
It's call optimized. What do you mean by
that?
Can we disable xdebug for a second?
Yeah. Sure.
And then it'll just you don't have to
disable it. Just type minus n on the
command line.
PHP minus n
and then the rest of your line.
And for
Yeah. And would
you now make this number
how can it be inf? That makes no
sense? So
what is the highest number you can do?
Yeah. It's just the numbers are too big.
Okay. Let's just stick with smaller numbers for
now. Let's not break it.
Let's run back and
Wait.
Say
I yeah. I was let's pick seven
as a good number.
Okay.
Now let's let's see how big the file
is that this has created.
Okay.
So we wanna do l l bar 10.
We must be this one here.
We'll take human readable side of this.
That's not that well, let's just go
what is the human readable of 734?
It's because I'm not actually using alias, so
that's an alias for something else. I think
I think so let's just
the old school
It's still going to be showing '3 and
07/1934.
Yeah. I yeah.
I'll quiet.
Do you want to open up the file?
I don't know because I'm getting loads of
things wrong here. Maybe we should just quit
while we're ahead.
There we go. There we go. Yeah.
Alright.
This makes sense. Right? So on your left
hand side, you still have two functions. You
have your main and your factorial.
Also,
the self columns added up together end up
at a hundred,
so there's nothing wrong with it.
You can see that spent time in the
factorial function is now more. It's now six
it's 60 ish percent,
and your color graph says that factorial
calls itself six times, which makes sense for
the number seven.
Indeed.
Now
there are a few other things in
q cache client. So at the top, you
have a few icons.
So you have the open file icon,
which lets you open a new file. You
have the the one next to it,
the text cycles. So
that is the clever bit in QCache Grind
that's
if you have a cycle like this, like
a recursive function, it the it's can detect
that
and
will then analyze things according to the cycle.
So if you get recursion, it's difficult to
create a graph because you never know how
you end up escaping
the recursion. Right?
I mean,
in your case, you can't really see this
because factorial itself
doesn't do anything else except calling itself.
So there's no no issue of it having
to be detected because
there's no other output part out of factorial.
But if factorial would have called my echo
or done something through another function,
it will show you these cycles as well.
So if you create a function, my factorial,
that's called factorial
and change change that in your scripts, then
it's a number. Yeah.
And that just calls factorial.
And then on line 17, you change factorial
to my factorial.
I mean, could we also just add an
echo that says hi with that? Yep. Echo
echoes
and function calls.
Alright. Gotcha.
So if you want to do that, you
can use a a print
f, for example. That would work, but echo
doesn't.
Exactly.
I like two lines. Okay.
Yeah. But I never bother a I never
bother with a constant. I just type slash
n.
Alright. Will we feel brave while we do
21?
Yeah. Sure.
Alright. Okay. You should get this 21 times.
So that's not so bad.
Do you want to check this file size
just to see how bad that can get?
3.9
k.
Yep. The false can get big.
Yep. Be aware of that. Anyway, let's open
them in QCachegrind and see what this is.
Woah.
You're making pretty pictures.
This is awesome.
Yeah. Cute cash grind, I think you should
take a screenshot.
This is this is why people use factorials
to do random cool wallpapers and stuff, isn't
it? Because you do get all these weird
recursive
looks.
It's amazing.
Alright. We'll take a screenshot. We'll put it
on there.
Should not
that. Okay. Yeah. Excellent.
But, yeah, now you see a cycle. Right?
You see a factorial my factorial
19 times,
but there's some other interesting that happened as
well.
Look at the percentages.
Oh, 642%
versus 582%.
Which makes no sense. I mean, you can
argue that main is a little bit larger
because of routing errors, but
that's old, isn't it?
This is this
is a bug.
It's a bug, an xdebug,
but I haven't figured out how to fix
it yet.
Okay. So we could skip over that for
now. I don't judge. I don't judge. It
does not particularly matter though because it still
allows you to detect the slow path.
But in this case, there's so little information
to slow. We know what the slowest part
is because it's just calling the function over
and over again.
So can I slow it down with some
crappy code?
Yes. Or do wanna go over this first?
Is there something here that we should Yeah.
I want to point out a few things.
Okay. So
the icons that I was just talking about,
the first one is detecting cycles. Just click
it off.
K.
Of course. Now you need to resize the
screen, I think, because it should have changed
information, and I still see the same thing.
No. It's not changed on my side either.
Can I refresh?
No. No. If it didn't change, then then
that's fine. So the cycle detection still didn't
have to kick in here because it's still
not interesting enough
because you still only get a circle.
This is something that is going to be
really hard to artificially create,
so I wouldn't bother trying it. We will
see this
when we run something interesting like Composer because
Composer has a recursive
dependency solver in it.
Okay. So the the only things to I
want to point out one more thing. If
on the top right tab,
you go to all colors.
Yep.
The top right. Oh, alright. Yeah.
And you select k.
Print f on the left hand side.
It is interesting because it shows you the
distance
from other functions.
So this sometimes tells you if this is
all in one
or
prominently from only one
other function,
it pretty much means that it
might make sense to inline it if it
takes up a lot of time.
Because function calls sorry. Not a lot of
time if there's a lot of calls
there.
Because function When you say testings, do you
mean how many
functions deep the call was?
How many
how many different levels,
stack
levels there were between the function that you
selected and the one on that list there.
Got you. Okay. So not necessarily from the
top, but from well, in this case, main
is from the top, of course, and the
distance is always going to be two here,
apparently. So to clarify that, if I had
a function,
my my factorial,
and I would also make this work, but
that would be a distance of three if
I updated these calls. Right? Right. Yes. Three
three stacks, three function calls. Right.
I
think that if you would put the print
f in the older function, it'd show you
other things, but it doesn't matter.
Anyway, recursion is the probably one of the
hardest things to to actually analyze because things
get confusing.
But this makes sense now. Right?
Yeah. Okay. That definitely.
Yep.
Shall we look at something more interesting?
Can we slow this down first?
Does that change anything from a
queue cash frame point of view? Will we
be able to see the bottleneck of one
of these functions? You will see
that's the overheads
of
the function calls themselves goes away.
So, yeah, I just put a u sleep
in in my factorial.
But I wanna say I only wanna do
it.
So let's say number is divisible by
by
then we do a use sleep.
How long do you sleep?
It's a microsecond.
Yeah. Six hundred. That that's six hundred microseconds.
Ah, you didn't We didn't return necessarily. So
I don't think we were actually getting a
proper view of it. Right? No. We didn't
actually check the output.
Should have written a unit test.
Okay. Let's let's try that again.
That actually might mean that we didn't quite
get the interesting output that we wanted.
Yeah. Yeah. I noticed that maybe on back
end.
The position is
39 is we're now at eight k. But,
yeah, it's definitely growing pretty
rapidly.
Yep.
So if we take a look at
wait. There we go.
So now you see it as load. It's
a little bit different. Right?
But I'm I'm not sure why you got
to use sleep every single time still.
Maybe my terrible coding?
That looks okay to me.
Yeah. It looks okay to me too. Okay.
So if if we get 39, that would
mean we should get
eight calls to use, like
I if we can Seven. If we seven.
If we do seven, we should get less.
So
Click on there.
Interesting.
Yeah. I don't understand this.
It still seems to be calling It seems
to called five times according to this. That's
correct. Yeah. And if you click on in
a bolt,
if you click on all
if you click on colors of u sleep
so select u sleep on the left,
and then all colors or colors,
it says my factorial call that. So if
you double click on my factorial no. Don't
click away. I'm trying to explain things. And
now go to source code.
You can see in my factorial that there
were five calls
u sleep
Yep. And 38 calls to factorial, which makes
sense.
Indeed.
Now turn on back to cycle detection, because
Doesn't change anything. That's
so what No.
Right.
You selected
a different function. Oh, sorry.
No. You
click on my pictorial, please. And
then leave colors in the top right.
Is there a question?
Do you, Crystal, raises a hand?
Yep.
If you have a question,
you can type it in, and we will
read out and handle that for you. No
problem.
Any in any case, I would like to
see in something
interesting instead of our contrived examples
because then you can actually explain things.
Alrighty
then. Yep. So do you want her to
compose her sample or go straight to the
seller?
Ask
her to compose her sample first.
Oh. No. Just saying hi. Hello. Hello, back?
I can say hello in many languages.
How
about
Mandalin?
So you're not going to pick the language.
I can pick the languages. How
about Gaelic?
Hello? That's simple enough.
Alright.
We won't make this a language lesson. We
will No. Let's not do that.
Because I don't want to be showing up
as a
well, terrible languages.
So
we have this composer dot json and I
have put together with two dependencies.
Now can I just run PHP
composer install?
I don't know why you have composer.
It's just installed by brew.
If it's installed by brew, I would like
to see the first line of it.
Yep.
We can do that. Just type ahead and
that name.
Oh, you can do it. Okay. So that
should work. You need to make sure that
the PHP is actually in the path and
it is not. So that's what I wanted
to check. User bin and PHP means it's
in the path. Yep. Good.
Alright.
Run it.
Okay. The first time, it's you said you
wiped out the caches,
so run this once more.
Yep. Okay. That should be it. And now
let's open a file with QCache client.
Yeah. I don't know what name it is,
but which
one would it be? A lovely 66 k.
So that's not so bad.
Woah.
Yeah. That's interesting for the trivial or simple
one. Look
at there was actually a learning moment on
the command line.
Can you switch to your terminal?
You see that? What it says there?
Garbage at the end of the cost line.
So this is something that has to do
with memory profiling.
QCache or cache clients' formats doesn't understand
a negative cost,
so it doesn't understand that if memory gets
freed, you have a negative cost.
So although memory profiling exists
in xdebug,
the visualization
with cache client isn't always the greatest.
Got it. So that's what I wanted to
point out here.
So, I mean, right off the bat, this
is,
I mean, information overload for such a simple
composer dot JSON.
Well, composers and trivial code. Right? It's That
that's true. Yeah. Exactly.
How do we start to make heads and
tails of this then? Yeah.
Make it a little bit bigger that at
the bottom screen.
Bottom tab should yeah. Drag it up.
Alright. So
by default, what it will do is
k, there will be another learning moment in
a second. What it's what it will do
is it will only show anything that's more
than 5%, I believe.
But what is the interesting bit, if you
follow the the the complicated
parts, the one with the thick arrows
Mhmm. What is the what is just follow
follow it from the top to the bottom
and see what it does.
Just read out the function names. So we
start off with main, and then we've got
require far
composer bend.
Then we've got xdebug handler check
followed by xdebug handler restart followed by xdebug
hand xdebug handler do restart followed by a
PHP pass through.
Yes.
What can what can you infer from this?
The the complicated path is xdebug and not
not I don't know.
So okay.
That is a perfectly good answer. Let's find
out then. Right? So if you click on
the green well, the that says xdebug handler
check.
Yep. Double click. Sorry.
And then at the top, select source code,
and then scroll down. Oh,
so this is annoying because it uses the
FAR file.
Do you want me just to
open this? See that
well, you can't just open it in FIM.
Got it.
But it says here I can add the
folder
of this file to the source folder list.
Yeah. But QCat current doesn't understand far colon
slash slash as a file prefix.
Oh, got it. Okay.
See, I have don't have this problem locally
because I run this. I run Composer not
through the far file. I just have a
checkout of it, but that's too complicated to
do here.
So although Composer might be an interesting thing
to look at because we can't look at
the source code,
isn't the most interesting thing.
But we'll explain what this is anyway. Basically,
what it says is that what a check
function does is it checks whether xdebug is
loaded,
and then it restarts PHP
without xdebug loaded.
So the profile that we have is basically
just a bootstrap,
which then disables xdebug. So you don't get
a profile of something interesting.
You only get it off the bootstrapping thing
that starts compose a bit where the interesting
things are happening.
Ah, okay. So Composer
finds it necessary to disable xdebug. So if
you want to profile
composer,
you need to turn off that behavior.
Does that make sense?
Yeah. So composer is xdebug aware and disables
it because, generally, you're not profiling
Composer but the thing that it's running.
Well, the the reason why Composer disables xdebug
because they believe that it slows things down
too much.
Okay. So So how do we
Let's go to the command line,
and we basically, what we need to do
is export a specific environment variable that turns
off this behavior.
So this is only something you're going to
have if you're profiling a composer.
Normally, you don't have to do this. So
the thing to export is I need to
look this up because I can't remember.
It's composer underscore allow underscore xdebug equals one,
all in capitals.
Composer underscore allow underscore
xdebug
equals one. Equals one. Got it.
Okay. Now run it again.
See, it now winds at you.
Okay. You need to make sure
check which files have been created because I
think it has created two files.
Nope. It's it's it has overwritten. It's okay.
I just
It is it must be good. Yep. So
open it up, and we'll see again.
So what's happened now?
So here's something
here, but
it's changed the paths a little bit. Yeah.
Click on main because it doesn't have a
function selected at the moment.
Oh, there we go. There we It's just
stuck. It's stuck it's got stuck somewhere, and
I don't remember where.
And now
you actually got some interesting information. Right?
Yeah. This this tree is much larger. The
tree is longer. Yes. And if you go
down a little bit
so there, you see the cycle thing in
there on the left hand side? Just yeah.
It's just behind your
see there? The cycle six where it says
that? Yep. Got it. So that is your
likely
although I don't know composer code where it
does the recursive loading of stuff.
So there is some weird things in there
that I don't know how it does.
But the branch point where it goes from
one to three
so if you go up a little bit
in the in the tree, just scroll down
here. So the do run
basically calls five functions or five functions that
we can see.
One takes a third,
one takes a tenth, and one takes a
half,
approximately.
Yep. So you can see here, well, which
two things take up the most amount of
time? It's not the one in the middle.
Right? It's that's only 10%, so we're not
interested in that.
But the thing that takes the most amount
of time is the 52%
here.
Yeah. Let's say it here. Yeah.
So
well, if you want to inspect that branch,
double click on what it says there on
the to run.
And then you get to three further down.
So the thickest line is always your slow
path.
Okay. So the the thickness of the line
correlates to how much of the CPU cycles
that
execution took? Right. Okay. Yeah. Pretty much.
And, yeah, well, let's go down and see
where it ends up.
I
don't know. Composer and so but you see
this the solver. That's basically what I was
trying to get at. Yeah. So we come
down to do install, and then there's quite
a hefty split where we go 6%
down the right hand path. And on the
left hand path, we're at 35%
where the majority of that is 20%
of some sort of dependency resolver
rules.
Yep. And then we have quite an even
distribution across the next four calls,
kind of four to 5% each.
Yep. That's basically what it says. So there's
probably not much that can be optimized here
because they they know what they've been doing
there.
Because this recursive code is so critical to
composer, they spend a lot of time optimizing
that.
So I think we struggle
finding a performance bottleneck in it.
So True. But we do have a very
nice way to to Exactly. Maximize that. It's
like, you know, we can kind of see
that call graph and and see where the
time is being spent, which is really interesting.
Exactly. So what I would recommend that we
do now is we double click on this
compose the dependence and resolve resolver solve to
make that our our current note. Yeah.
That one. And now we just leave this.
Don't click on anything else. Just close q
cache brand.
Close it? Yep.
Okay. And now let's go to your more
complicated example.
Okay.
So we also The reason why I said
don't click on anything is because it remembers
the function that you have selected.
So that allows us to compare between the
two files.
Okay.
So from here,
let me just make sure I definitely remove
it. So there's no lock fail here, which
means
it's gonna have to build a dependency graph.
Well, it needs to do that any case
if you type composer update.
What I don't want to do is have
this guy on it.
You're running composer of xdebug enabled. This has
a major impact on run time performance.
Thus.
So this is a pretty large composer.
This is the project.
Yeah. Just show the composer dot JSON.
Line 28 down to
a hundred And, of course, and, of course,
all of these will have their own dependencies
again too. Exactly. Yeah. A lot of Symphony
stuff here, which is gonna have complicated dependency
trees and doctrine as well, database stuff, I
guess, is gonna rich. Okay. So
No. This is a more typical thing that
yeah. It takes ages with x with with
xdebug enabled.
So let's take a minute without xdebug.
We're in for the long haul here. Right?
Yes. Take a time for people to get
some questions and if there's anything they want
us to cover over there.
Or, alternatively,
xdebug three that I'm working on
will speed us up dramatically.
But I wouldn't suggest we install that right
now.
So what's different than xdebug three that gives
it the performance performance
benefits?
Because it is much more clever on when
and what when and what it turns on.
And there are some algorithms
in there, especially that have to do with
the stack
that are a lot more
are a lot better with allocating memory.
So what xdebug two does for every time
a function is called, it creates this memory
structure,
which
has the function name in it, where it
is called from arguments,
and so on and so on. And that
structure
is pretty big.
At the end of the function,
this memory is freed.
When the next function is called, it's created
again, and it is freed again. Now if
you do this two times, that's fine. But
typical
bigger
applications like Composer,
this will happen hundreds of thousands of times.
Now what xebit three does, it's instead of
allocating and freeing it every time, it basically
has a continuous set of memory allocated
Like a ring and will reuse
it instead of freeing it.
So it will detect when it doesn't have
enough memory allocated and will allocate a chunk
more, but it doesn't free it until the
script ends.
Ah, okay.
So, potentially, it uses more memory, but it
is significantly faster.
Cool. Very cool.
I'm waiting for people to expect xdebug three
to be
be stable,
considerable, usable.
Well, I use it all the time. I
think it well, the test passed, so I
guess that makes it stable.
But I'd I would like to create, like,
a a tech preview release
once I've made all the breaking changes in
it
because lots of names of settings change and
things like that to make it easier to
use and not having to remember all 70
different settings that we have.
And
yeah. So
the idea is that there will at least
be a release candidate when PHP eight comes
out
and hopefully a final release soon after that.
But and that is November.
That's that's how things stand now.
But if you want to play with it,
some GitHub should work.
But please read the upgrade guide
because things have changed.
Definitely.
So does that clear question or was it
a comment?
It it's a comment to say thank you
for xdebug three. Well, you are welcome.
Yeah. You know, I think a lot of
people get a lot of you know, xdebug
is one of those tools that just becomes
invaluable once you understand the basics and and
how it works.
Profile in general, you know, xdebug is a
profiler for PHP. So
Well, I think most people don't use it
as a profile, but as it's as it's
as a step debugger, but yeah.
Yeah. I guess maybe it's it's just where
my head is at. You know?
I I I I I see the value
in profile, and I think it's invaluable for
any code you have in production. You know,
you need to know how it behaves in
that environment and profiling it and and understanding
it. Extract metrics from it, doesn't heat grass,
flame grass, all these things. Like, there's just
so much you can do with this stuff
to really understand your application.
Yeah. Then again, xdebug's profile is not meant
to run-in a production environment
because it's meant to run a development environment
like we're doing now because it well,
I said has too much overhead or maybe
had too much overhead because
with xdebug tree, you would be able to
selectively turn it on for just a single
request.
That's why I could do sampling in my
production environment then. Yeah. Well, it's not quite
that easy, but it
as long as you don't enable any features,
it doesn't slow anything
down beyond, like, a few percent.
But if you want to to do, like,
real time application performance monitoring, which is basically
what you're getting at the moment, xdebug is
not made for that. Okay. It is it's
more more for developers trying to find performance
bottlenecks
in a normal situation and not depending on
how your system is doing at the moment.
Ah, okay.
I understand. Robert's
on a on a chat's having an interesting
comment, and I agree with him.
Which comment? Sorry.
He says, can you run htop in the
background so we see the numb the numbers
jumping around and and not that composer's just
frozen?
Oh, so, apparently, you're getting comments much much
faster than I am because it's only just
popped in here now. So, yeah, can I
run htop in the background so we can
play it? Yeah.
Where
I'm just following the YouTube stream on my
other screen.
So I see the the text the moment
I type it.
Yeah. I've got it coming through the the
streaming software that we use. I think it's
a little bit of latency, but hopefully not
too bad. So and I bet you by
the time I brew install htop,
it's probably gonna finish up. Oh, yeah.
I'll do my best.
Come on, bro.
Take that away. Know how to pronounce that
surname.
I mean, if you don't have htop, you
can just try top instead.
We'll get a nice color. So
That's true.
Yeah. And I'll probably wanna run it on
a full screen.
It's pretty. Yeah.
Sorted.
So PHP uses 98%
support line.
Firefox uses a 30%, but oh, this probably
because there's other video for you. Right? Yeah.
Okay. That makes sense.
I haven't looked at normal top for ages
because I always use htop.
Htop is taking its its sweet time. So
oh, there we go. Let's drop
out.
There we go. It's much prettier, isn't it?
It is.
Yep. But
yes. Can I filter an h shop? I'm
not I'm not that familiar with visual. Can
I filter yeah? Well,
f four. Yeah. I how
do you type f four into terminal window?
Yeah. Okay.
And now we're just looking at PHP stuff,
and we can see composer.
It's quite good on the memory consumption. You
know, we're setting a 2.5%
there. The CP is
is obviously doing a lot of computation there.
Well, it would be nice if it could
use all 16 of your course.
I've heard a rumor that potentially,
compulsive two
has concurrency slash parallel support. Is that right?
Okay. I don't I don't know, actually. Yeah.
People are like I've done a couple of
streams now on PHP technology. Mostly around containers.
And the last few times, people have been
like, oh, you have to use composer too
because it does all the downloading in parallel,
which I'm assuming means that that spends up
a thread per core and has them doing
the dependencies.
But it is the downloading of files. It's
the IO, the disk IO, the network IO
that is parallelized is not the solver.
I don't think the set algorithm can be
parallelized.
Yeah. I don't think you'd be able to
break that up.
That would be very complicated. You'd like if
private well, you just have to map register
solver. That would be crazy. Yeah. But
because it's recursive, you can't, I think. Good
point.
Do you want to see how big the
the cache client files get cutting?
I don't think you want to. I'm not
sure I do. Yeah. That's what I was
gonna say. Why don't we run a watch?
If you don't I don't have a watch.
What kind of machine is this? Okay.
It's yours.
Oh, dear.
Don't open the file in FIM.
See, this is the thing. Right? Those files
can get big.
The
thing is that
q cache client
actually sup supports g zed compressed files,
but xdebug doesn't do so yet.
Actually, I don't think I have a ticket
for that. Let me
let me add check that.
Let's see if it's still
I mean, I'm assuming the reset that it's
still CPU bound right now means that it's
still on the software stage rather than the
download stage.
Yes. Absolutely.
Considering it's not going to download any files
because it's in your cache. Hoping so.
But it should be in your cache because
you ran it before.
It's it's the
2.3 k, counting. CPU is still burned, running
for ten minutes.
Wow.
Yeah. This takes ages. Right? I really I
really want to see how fast xdebug three
is now.
I think it'd be a good experiment. Oh,
yeah. Definitely. We get to see the improvements
there. I may do that in my my
spare time this week. Just to absolute curiosity,
man.
I think it'd be faster to compile xdebug
and run it again than waiting for this
to get finished.
I just yeah. I can go to xdebug.
I mean, we've got time.
Yep. We have, well, another twenty minutes. Yep.
That was I wanted to search GitHub.
What are you doing now?
With the Chrome xdebug,
but I'm sure the minute I get over
to my terminal
now
Just go finish.
No. No. No. About finish. Just open another
terminal. We'll be fine.
Did it change things again?
Yeah. Oh.
There we go.
That's an annoying bug. Okay.
So clone xdebug.
I need to is master okay? Do you
want me to pull a branch down? Or
No. It needs to be master.
Alright. Can I just show I haven't I
haven't gotten I can't see anything you typed
on?
Oh, that's very annoying.
I can't keep switching back. There's
no make fail. What's going on?
I can't see what you're doing, so I
can't tell.
Did you so what are the things that
you're trying to type? Now you Let's stop
the share again and I'll bring it back.
It's just, obviously, some sort of
glitchy bug happening.
Okay. So it's here screen two.
So
I I cloned it and I typed make,
but there's no make in process.
Funny.
There's this process for this. First thing to
type is PHPIs.
PHPIs?
Oh, I I zed e. Yes. Yes. It
should be with an s, but that's a
recognize.
That works? Dot slash configure.
Robert, it's not a camera output that's lagging.
It's
some graphics issue
with sharing the screen. I am running the
Pixar
pair.
So
Okay. Yeah. Potentially,
Harrison.
Did that work? Yep.
Yep. And now type make.
No. You got a warning.
Warnings are there to be ignored.
It's true.
For you. I need to fix them.
It does sometimes different compilers will give different
warnings.
I can always ask at dash w all.
Alright? That treats warnings. Is that hers, if
I remember correctly?
So the flags that I've set up for
my own compile script does actually do that.
It does w all and a whole bunch
of other things. Okay. It works. Make install.
What about our running composer process? Is that
are we You're not on Windows.
This works.
In Unix's, you can override files, and anything
that's still memory works just fine.
Can you type PHP minus v in?
Sorry. You kinda dropped that there, minus.
V for victory. Oh,
shiny.
Shiny indeed.
Now do you want to go to your
pseudo projects?
Not shiny. C two
has dropped or it had dropped drastically.
I'm assuming this is about finished.
I think it is zipping things. Yeah.
Oh, it's it's showing
showing you now. Yeah.
Okay.
Show the composer output on
your terminal.
Where did we go?
It's in the top one.
Okay. That should once this is done, we
just run it again and see how much
faster. This this took us what?
Thirteen minutes?
If I run htop again,
it's
been filter
fourteen and a half minutes.
Assuming it finishes in the next thirty seconds,
fifteen minutes, it'll take.
And our output down here is currently at
3.4 gig.
There we go.
Fifteen minutes.
Yeah. It's done, though.
Yep. K. So should I rename this file
before we run it again?
Yes.
It's a big file. Hopefully, you have enough
disk space.
It should be alright. So bar
cam
name, and I'll just actually bring it here.
Oh, why am I crashing on the anyway,
it doesn't matter.
So we wanna run composer install again. Right?
Yep. Same thing.
Yeah. What sort of bit of walk fail?
Well,
why?
Because
the first time you run it, it already
did all these things.
Then we run it with x then we
run it with compose with
compose and not disabling xdebug.
So it should be the same thing. It
should be no difference.
But the log files are now sorted. I
does that not mean it doesn't run the
solver
again?
Sorry. What? Because the log files there, it
won't run the solver again. Yeah. It's gonna
use the log file. First the first profile
that we made
Composer disabled xdebug.
Right? And then it ran.
Then we used the environment variable
to tell Composer not to disable xdebug, but
we didn't remove any any log files.
That was we the first time we ran
it was on the simple example, though. This
is the first time we've run Composer install
on this proposal this directory.
No. We've just run this.
Oh.
Oh, yes. You're right. You're right. Yes. Remove
the log file. You're absolutely right.
Sorry.
So
Okay. So once one thing that you need
to change, otherwise, it's unfair.
Mhmm.
See what it says, what the error message
says.
Has been renamed.
Yes.
So we need to change the setting in
PHP I nine.
So you want me to close this? Yeah.
Abort this, remove the log file, and then
we open PHP I nine. Remove the log
file first before we forget.
Okay. So I haven't finished resolving it, so
we're okay. So now we wanna modify
this.
So instead of profile enable, it is xdebug
dot mode.
You can just leave this in there. It
doesn't matter.
Equals profile.
Yeah.
You still got a warning, but yeah. It's
a semicolon,
not a hash.
Actually, I don't know.
I think And then I can just run
to post install again? Yeah.
Yes.
Okay.
Should
we take a look at that other cache
frame just now? Yeah. Let's do that. Well,
this runs. Right. Let's stop that. There's no
there's no log file here. And I'm just
gonna run it with time. Let's get a
a number from it so I don't need
to run each top.
Okay. Okay.
Here, cache grind and my local file here.
It takes some time.
It's a big fault. It needs to pass
three dot three gigabytes of profiling
information.
Let's
give it another minute.
That grind will have would not have been
able to handle this.
The file is too big.
Yeah. It really just takes as much time.
There's no much you can do on this.
I
wonder what's gonna load first this this profile
for xdebug three and compulsive.
It's still loading it.
It is. Oh, we have a progress part
of here. Oh, yeah. It's about 30%,
maybe maybe 25%.
Yeah. This is where
the disc disc performance over Mac really sucks.
Alright. No. It's the next time Derek is
on the stream, bring my Linux laptop to
the party. Mhmm.
Much faster.
I also believe that the
error messages
are causing a slowdown as well.
And I Oh, yeah.
I think that the next ebook three, I
actually made sure that it doesn't show negative
information in there so that will be faster
on the site too. Just loading the phone.
But I'm not a % certain.
Profiler.
I'm just creating a ticket for myself. So
I don't forget that.
So dance?
Yep.
Yeah. I think it's only halfway through.
Yeah.
Ain't sure what to do about that.
I wonder how many lines are in there.
What does it show in the console output?
It it tells you how many lines which
line it is parsing.
So the number in the middle,
that's the line number.
Yeah. That's a big line.
225,000,000.
My computer is
going haywire.
It's you don't have enough memory, I think.
I think that's your problem. It's starting to
swap now.
No.
The file is only 3.3 gig, and I've
got 32 gig around.
Yeah. But how do you think what do
you think QCache Crime does for this?
I assumed it was loading three gig into
memory.
Well, you have top find out.
Okay.
That was a mistake.
Running w c was a mistake?
Yeah.
I'm only using half my memory.
Yeah. But you also I have 1.3
gig as well. Yeah.
That is not a lot of swap for
that much memory.
I normally have swap disabled. I've just not
done it on a Mac.
Not sure whether you can, actually. I mean,
I've swapped disabled on my machine as well,
but it has a bit more memory.
Yeah. I'm not sure how big that fail
is.
4,000,
40 thousand, hundred thousand
Half gigabytes.
27,000,000
lines.
And it's about halfway done.
But I think you run into swap here
because it's not getting bigger.
Oh. It's done. That's why.
So,
yeah, you can see now it's stuck on
the on the software,
and it now takes 90% of the time.
Right? And you remember previously, it was 26%.
Yep.
But you can see how often things have
been called.
Yeah. That's
700,000
times. Thousand times.
Interesting
that this call is 700
I mean, that's only 4.77%,
whereas the function call twice is 53.
Yep. But look at call goes down here.
Yeah. Yeah.
At the 1,400,000
and the 1 3
Yeah. And That is a lot of function
calls.
And this is where xdebug was actually terribly
slow for doing that kind of stuff.
I think it's done, by the way.
Oh, okay. So can I close this one
down?
Is it is it done? Composer is installed,
isn't it? It finished.
It has. Yeah. It only took two hundred
and fifty seconds this time. So six minutes
instead of fifteen. Fifteen.
Sorry. That's not true. It's four minutes, not
six minutes.
Yes. Four minutes. Okay. So while we shut
this one,
there's not gonna be anything different between this
queue cache going to the other one. Right?
This the only difference there was that the
xdebug was significantly faster. Exactly. Yeah.
So that's what I've been spending my the
last few months on making this go not
suck too much.
Because now I mean, four minutes is still
not great, but
it's not sixteen minutes or whatever or fifteen
minutes.
And I haven't even spent time optimizing composers
specifically. So
but yeah. Anyway, so if you would ask
me how would I
make xdebug go faster, I would do exactly
the same thing.
I would use file grind, creating cache grind
files and loading them into,
you know, k cache grind in my case
or q cache grind to analyze the profile
and see where it's slow
in the exact same way.
And the process of identifying what
is slow here is just following the percentages
and the bigger lines and trying to find
the functions where most of the time is
being spent. Absolutely. Or what is often a
good thing of doing it on the left
hand side, you have the inclusive in self.
If you click on the word self,
the things at the top are the functions
that where most of the time is taken
without it's calling all the functions.
Okay.
And so I just go down the list
and see whether there's anything interesting in it.
Okay. Oh, yeah. You just be sorting this
list based on self
and Yep. Looking for the functions for us
by the most time. The first function I
would look in in this case is the
the one that is currently selected. It's called
two times,
but it takes up 11%.
That is a lot. Unfortunately,
your composer
you don't have the source code locally.
So this was what showed me the code
here. Yeah. So if I compiled composer,
then I would have so I guess that's
that's a important point here is if you're
gonna profile
you can't profile something distributed as a far
a far. You would have to have that
quote built. No. You can't you can't profile
it, but you can't see the source code.
K. Okay. Because QCache client or k crashing
doesn't understand the file format. Right?
And if we take a look at the,
you know, the callers, we can see where
that function is being called from. Do we
get any visibility beyond that, or is it
is it just If you click on colors,
you can see where this is called from,
but you can also see that's in the
graph already
because the one that is selected is the
red one in the middle.
Okay.
And if you can see what is if
in the in the call graph here down
here, you can see who who called it
because it's the node above it. Ah, right.
Gotcha. Okay. But you can see there's all
the functions got two to 2,000,000 times
down here. Yeah.
Blue one. Oh, yeah. That's there we go.
Okay. Got it.
So Is there any
any difference that we would apply? Like, right
now, I I feel like we're kind of
identifying functions called based on their c p
CPU performance. And is there anything different that
has to happen if I wanna find bad
actors with memory allocations?
Yep. You see the worst time in your
menu bar?
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Ah.
Change it to memory.
So simple.
It's the same idea.
But then I have to make a big
caveat here. There's that memory
profiling is not nearly as accurate because, as
I mentioned,
it is impossible to see
the negative use of memory when things get
freed.
And, also, PHP's garbage collector can kick in
at any time.
Right. Sometimes you see memory being freed
that isn't
actually getting freed
at the point where it says it is
going to be freed because it's a garbage
collect they're kicking in. Now with Composer specifically,
that is not a problem because Composer disables
PHP's garbage collector
because it would make it
two or three times as slow.
And you don't really care in command line
applications. Right?
Yeah. Because, I guess, typically, they're not long
running. They the the PHP will exit is,
I guess. Right. So anything where you you'd,
like, run, like, a a PHP process that
you want to run for hours, you want
to have the garbage collector turned on. But
if it's a one shot script, then you
don't really care.
That makes sense.
And, yeah, you don't really want to wait
for garbage being collected.
Okay.
Is there anything else you feel we should
cover before we wrap this up? Because I
feel like
I don't think we have anything at the
moment that I still can talk about. I
mean, I would suggest you play
around with your own PHP applications. I mean,
the people are listening. Oh, and your you,
of course, as well.
And,
yeah, that's pretty much it.
Alright. That was the same.
That was awesome. That was really insightful again.
I look at the head of this first.
And
it's just so much information. Like,
it's a really cool tool that we have
the ability to just inject like, I mean,
installing xdebug and running that in their application
was so trivial.
That that was great.
Yep. You turn it on. That that's pretty
much it.
And the speed performance of xdebug three was
fantastic. So great job there. I think I
I didn't I knew you said it was
faster. I wasn't expecting to go from fifteen
minutes to sub four minutes. That's pretty impressive.
Yeah. I wasn't
expecting that either, to be fair.
Surprised it wrote itself. Awesome.
Alright, Chris.
Sorry. I mean, I know with compose, it
is the recursive calling
that happens so often, and I know that
was
a contentious point.
Yeah.
Alright. Well, thank you very much for taking
the time out of your day to join
me and go through all this. This is
really useful. I'm sure others are gonna find
this fantastic as well. So thank you again,
Derek.
I'll tweet out the link to the video
once this, Rawkode.
Alright. Perfect. Well, thank you again. I'll speak
to you soon. Thank
you for tuning in, and I'll see you
all next time. Thanks. Bye.